you can't tell from looking at me but I
actually grew up deep in the woods my
childhood home was an Antiquated Log
Cabin surrounded by so much Forest you
couldn't even see the distant Road in
the winter so I spent my free time
playing among the trees climbing their
branches and seeing what Treasures I
could discover among their Roots we
relied on wood from those trees to warm
our house cook our meals and heat up
water some provided food others syrup
and they all provided shade that
childhood while certainly imperfect gave
me a deep appreciation for nature I was
so grateful for everything the trees
provided that I did the 21st century
equivalent of begging Gaia to turn me
into a dryad and got a tattoo of an oak
tree on my arm but I was by no means the
first person to pay my respects to The
Majestic tree humans around the world
have been doing that for thousands of
years in ways that were immortalized in
our midst
even without all of the vital practical
things trees provide it's hard not to
see them as Divine or magical their
sheer size can seem to connect the Earth
to the heavens and their centuries-long
lifespans mean a single tree can watch
over a family or Community for several
Generations long enough that its origin
Fades into Legend even the deciduous
trees that shed their leaves every year
Blossom again in the spring showing that
they weren't dead at all just taking a
little nap before it returned with its
gifts it was easy for many of our
ancestors to interpret something so
Immortal and abundant as the gift or
even embodiment of a God but I think the
reciprocal nature of our relationship to
trees is the real reason they're so
common in folklore we rely on them but
they also rely on us and beneath every
story about the Wonders trees provide
there's a sometimes not so hidden
message about what will happen if we
don't take care of them in Thailand
Buddhist folklore tells of a tree called
called the narathon or macalaphon that
grows fruit in the shape of young women
according to one of the jataka or a
series of texts that describe the
various lives of the Buddha the trees
were planted in a sacred grove by the
god Indra to protect Modi Buddha's wife
in a previous life in that life the
Buddha was known as Prince vesantara the
son of a woman who was beloved by Indra
vesantara was so generous that he was
exiled from his own kingdom for giving a
gift that he shouldn't have while in
Exile vesantara and Maddie traveled
through the legendary himavanta Forest
full of dangerous creatures it's said
that Indra shaped the fruit like a young
woman to entice ill-intentioned men who
would be drawn to the narathon for
obvious and disgusting reasons thus they
would be distracted from chasing Mahdi
if a man picked the narathon's fruit and
took it to his bed gross he would
quickly find himself sterile and
stripped of any powers he might possess
women however were immune to the fruit
and instead could use it as a fertility
Talisman if they waited for the fruit to
fall naturally from the tree after a
week of growing the location of the
legendary himavanta forest and the Grove
of narathon trees is unknown but you can
still find Street vendors in Thailand
who claimed to sell these woman-shaped
dried fruits to boost fertility just a
few years ago a video circulating on
social media showing what appeared to be
one of these narathon trees got a lot of
attention though the videos were never
verified as real this shows that the
myth of woman-shaped fruit is Alive and
Well in Southeast Asia so for some
cultures trees and their fruits were
gifts from the gods to us humans other
stories positioned trees as the
Botanical embodiment of a mystical
figure for example the dryads who helped
Inspire my tattoo were minor Greek
goddesses or nymphs who inhabited and
looked after trees and Woodlands dryads
served as the spirits of trees and when
they flourished their tree thrived when
a dryad was sick or injured so was their
tree originally the term dryad only
referred to the spirits of oak trees
which were considered sacred to Zeus ash
trees were guarded by melie certain
Mountain trees by oriadis and fruit
trees by meliadis Laurels were inhabited
by the Daphne named for the water nymph
Daphne who was unlucky enough to catch
the god Apollo's attention after running
from the Sun God's advances Daphne
implored Gaia the Earth Mother for help
she was transformed into a laurel tree
and saved from Apollo's Relentless
Pursuit only for The Laurels she
protected to become sacred to the God
she fled dryad eventually became the
general term for any treatment due to
the oak tree's prevalence in ancient
Greece and their connection to the king
of the Gods as spirits of the forest
dryads could make plants grow or die as
they pleased but mostly they acted as
stewards of of their Woods this idea
that trees and other elements of nature
each had their own Living spirit
certainly wasn't unique to the Greeks
animism was practiced by many of
Europe's pre-christian pagans like the
Celts and Germanic tribes who respected
or even worshiped the spirits of
inanimate things those Spirits weren't
necessarily considered gods however as
far as we can tell the Celtic Tree of
Life or cran Baha was Central to Celtic
culture but it didn't represent a
specific important deity instead it
represented the balance of forces in
nature the Celts saw a beauty in the way
that the tree's roots stretched deep
below ground while its branches
stretched High into the heavens
demonstrating the connection between
different Realms of the cosmos to the
Celts the tree of life was an oak tree
likely because these were the oldest
tallest trees in their sacred forests so
tall that they would often be struck by
lightning which would be interpreted as
a sign of their favor by the gods plenty
of other cultures had their own tree of
life that rep presented the balance of
natural forces but some of them also
provided connections between different
worlds these are often called world or
Cosmic trees we mentioned The Baobab
tree in our episode on yaraba folklore
this tree was said to be the home of the
orisha in their Heavenly realm before
abatala created land down here on Earth
The Baobab is often called the African
tree of life because of the way it looms
over the desert providing shade and
hundreds of valuable uses with its bark
and sap those trees can live for 3 000
years and grow over a hundred feet tall
and 50 feet wide many origin myths for
The Baobab involve it being planted
upside down in one story the balbab tree
kept walking after it was planted so God
ripped it up and replanted it upside
down in another the hyena was assigned
the job of planting The Baobab tree but
found it so ugly that he planted its
branches in the dirt another Cosmic Tree
on the other side of the world is the
seiba sacred to many people throughout
the tropics including the Maya of
mesoamerica and the Taino from Puerto
Rico and the Caribbean the Mayans called
it yakshay and believed it was a world
tree that acted as the scaffolding for
their Universe the saiba tree's
irregular Bloom cycle demonstrated the
unbreakable and traversable tether
between life and death so it's no
surprise that yakshay's roots and
branches served as portals to the Mayan
afterlife Spirits could climb them to
reach their final destinations the seiba
tree is such an important cultural
symbol that when a 400 year old sahiba
blossomed on Vieques Island after being
ravaged by hurricanes Irma and Maria the
Islanders saw it as a sign of Hope and
encouragement that they would bounce
back from all the damage perhaps the
most well-known world tree from
mythology is the Norse igdrasil this
Cosmic tree was said to hold all the
nine worlds of the Norse Cosmos in its
roots and branches including midgard and
Asgard some sources claim that iggdrasil
is an ash tree but that's hotly debate
regardless of its exact species
idrisil's health is vital to the health
of the Norse universe and to their head
god Odin according to Legend Odin
sacrificed his own blood and his eye to
himself by voluntarily hanging from
idrisil for nine days as one does in
doing so he gained knowledge and wisdom
world trees serve the Paramount purpose
of balancing life forces and supporting
a stable universe but if you have more
selfish desires you'll want to look for
a wishing tree throughout the world
ancient and modern people alike have
made wishes on trees by tying ribbons to
their branches hammering special coins
into their bark or tossing notes into
their canopies Hindu myths tell of the
kelp of rishka a wish-granting tree that
emerged from the primordial Waters
during a legendary battle between the
gods or Devas and demons or asuras after
being poisoned the Devas searched for a
healing Elixir at the bottom of a Milky
ocean but in their churning brought up
many Treasures from the depths it's
unclear what type of tree the Cowper
vishka is though many compare it to the
Banyan one of India's most sacred trees
myths like these make trees sacred or at
least worthy of our care and protection
other stories act as cautionary tales
that scare us into looking after our
Woody friends Japanese folklore has
tales of the jibako a Yokai who forms
when enough blood has been violently
spilled on its roots these trees who
have seen too little kindness and
receive too few thanks turn hostile and
use their sharp branches to grab anyone
who gets too close and drain their blood
having grown up surrounded by trees in a
lifestyle slightly more reminiscent of
our ancestors than most I personally
understand the importance of treating
them well a sick Tree on your property
can fall down on your possessions or
spread rot to its neighbors trees become
the stuff of nightmares when we neglect
them but they literally Keep Us Alive
when we give them the bare minimum of
care let let's all Take a Hint from
these ancient cultures all over the
world and stop every once in a while to
see trees for the true gifts they are
clearly having a close connection with
nature is something very personal to me
which is why I'm so excited to tell you
about a new series on PBS Terra called
women of the earth it's a series that
introduces you to women who are
pioneering movements to heal the Earth
from climate change there is a link in
the description we hope you check it out
and the rest of PBS's Earth month
playlist too